welcome back to age 20 special
relativity so in this
section we want to review the content of
the material but underlined with a few
questions and examples very similar to
the previous section it's just this one
is interleaved with
activities
so let me start by you know
bringing back two of those einstein
quotes which nicely relate to each other
in a sense that
their feet off each other the first one
is i have no special talent i'm only
passionately curious
about einstein
and the second one
it is a miracle that curiosity survives
formal education and i sincerely hope
that i didn't starve your curiosity
with this lecture quite the opposite um
we discussed here is just the starting
point of a wider discussion of general
relativity in your education at mit in
the physics department you could learn
about quantum mechanics quantum field
theories and a lot of physics is out
there which is super exciting
and
um
interesting
so it basically needs your curiosity in
order to tackle
challenging questions in physics today
[Music]
we started the discussion looking at the
background
which led einstein to make this
discovery his discoveries and
specifically the year 1905 in which he
was able to come out with five
papers all
you know breakthrough papers including
the theory of special relativity
his career didn't stop there he uh you
know developed the general theory of
relativity
uh and published a paper on this in 95
and his fame as a physicist really comes
out of of the predictions he made at
that time
so we set the context of this class and
we started with a question of
galilean transformation and whether or
not you can tell in a moving car
in a moving train car whether or not
this
whether or not this is actually moving
or stationary
and we show demonstrated that time and
acceleration is invariant in the
galilean transformation and then
therefore
since you cannot distinguish the the
strength of a force
in
to reference frames which move to each
other with moderate velocity
um
you cannot tell whether or not the train
car is moving or not
very important are the developments of
clocks and times and signal processing
of the time
um and we discussed this in the context
of trains and train lines but also in
einstein living in the city of vern with
you know a larger number of clock towers
which needed synchronization and even
working in the patent office
[Music]
certainly confronted him
with those questions at the time so time
is suspect that is really the clue or
the key
to
moving out from galilean transformation
into newtonian mechanics to
special relativity
you know when we
classify or when we look at specific
theories
we have to understand that their life is
in a context within a range of validity
and so classical mechanics is not wrong
because
it breaks down at large velocities it's
just only correct in the frame of slow
velocities
and relativity special relativity
also has its limitations as in
it only describes reference frames or
scenarios in which there is no
acceleration
between two reference
frames um going back to the the time or
questions of the time michaelson and a
number of other experiments leading to
the very same direction um was trying to
establish that there is an e7 the medium
in which light is moving and this
experiment at the time failed to
demonstrate if ether actually exists
his experiment used the light source and
a couple of mirrors in order to show
interference patterns and and those
interference patterns didn't manifest
themselves so he thought for a long time
that his experiment is limited or
that he has made a mistake but it turns
out that ether indeed doesn't exist
einstein tackles this problem by making
two postulates the first one
is that the principle of relativity
um that there's no preferred reference
frame if you want and the second that
the speed of light is constant
and constant and the same in our
reference phase
and in this class we use those two
postulates in order to derive everything
we know about special
relativity
so we looked at the implications and the
implications started from time dilation
length contractions we were able to
derive the loans factor and launch
transformation and we did this by
showing this light law here where you
you know
observe a ticking clock in which there's
two mirrors and lights bouncing back and
each time there's a bounce we count this
as one tick of the clock
so if the clock is moving the light has
to travel a longer distance and hence
time
is
delayed
and from just the geometry of this
problem we were able to derive the
scammer factor here
one over square root one minus beta
square the better is the velocity over
the speed of light
so as a first activity in today's class
i want you to think about
a clock which is moving with a photon
a clock which is moving with the speed
of light and also discuss
why isn't it possible to go faster than
the speed of light and why can you not
just keep accelerating
so think about this a little bit in the
live class we will have a discussion
but just come up with some sort of
answer of why this is the case
so here you know we have in the class
actually showed that there is a real
speed limit that if you try to go faster
faster will see velocity you run against
a boundary a real speed limit
if you think about keeping accelerating
giving more energy you find that the
amount of energy you need in order to go
faster and faster faster doesn't get you
to velocities which are faster and
faster and again
you enter a speed limit the speed of
light
an important topic in understanding some
of the paradoxes in special relativity
and some of the confusion
the concept of the relativity of
simultaneity
it can be illustrated quite nicely in
this example here where you have a
carriage train car
with light being emitted and clocks
which record this event those events at
the end
at each end of the train car
for the stationary person those clocks
will tick
in sync they will always show the same
check at the same time
but for somebody who's moving observing
this this train from a platform or
somebody who's moving with a relative
velocity towards this train car you will
see those clocks not ticking at the same
time
so
the
clear evidence is given in this picture
again where you see that the lights
being admitted in this in the center but
one side of the train car is hit first
and the second side is hit afterwards so
you see that the leaking leading clock
lacks
the leading clock in this example lags
behind
and so what you find here is that events
which are observed simultaneously for
one observer
in this case the person inside the
carriage
they don't necessarily they will not be
simultaneous for an observer who's
moving with the relative velocity
and that led us to understand to the
understanding of the poland the barn
paradox where
in
one example
the event of the front of the pole
hitting the back of the barn
and the event of the back of the pole
hitting the front of the barn there
simultaneously for the barn owner but
they're not simultaneously happening for
the person who's carrying the bar
carrying the pole
in this case the event
of hitting the back of the barn
corresponds to an event
or a simultaneous to an event where the
back of the pole is still sticking out
of the bond so there is a clear
disagreement but this agreement can be
resolved by understanding that
simultaneous events not necessarily or
are not simultaneous to
to observers
then we moved on to a variety of other
um
paradoxes in special relativity and the
most famous likely is the twin paradox
where we discussed that
a person moving away
um and then returning
is younger than the person who actually
stayed at rest
and we discussed that you know we were
able to use um
time dilation and length contraction in
order to quantificatively figure out the
difference in time
but we also discussed that the person
who is
moving away and then coming back needs
to be
needs to describe the the the journey
into different reference frames and from
the fact that you don't consistently can
describe this
sequence of events there's two reference
frames you can see the paradox
and the explanation extra extra
confusion
so here we have another activity um an
asymmetric travel so we discussed also
the example where two people move away
and then they come back in the symmetric
fashion but here we want to discuss the
case where there's three trends carol
stays on earth bob moves to star one and
alice moves to star two the distance to
star one is longer than the distance to
two two two star star two
so the question is you know in this
journey they both start and they both
return at the same time for carol
but which of the twins is the youngest
so again i invite you to just work this
out you can use
some numbers if you want a quantitative
answer or you can just reason about
okay and so the answer here
is that
bob is the youngest of the three once
they return to the to earth
and the the reason for this is the
distance he has to travel is the longest
hence his velocity has to travel in
is the largest and hence the effect of
time dilation for him is the biggest and
therefore he's going to be the youngest
of the three
all right we had a rather long
discussion about
waves and light doppler effect and
relativistic doppler effect
um
here just as a reminder the wave
equation for an electric field in vacuum
and the solution so the wave equation is
the second
uses second derivative with space and
time and the solution is simply can be
expressed as a cosine which is a
function of space and time
we have talked about light quite a bit
um and just as a reminder
is the energy of a photon is related via
the planck einstein relation to the
frequency
um so the higher the frequency the
higher the
the higher the um
the energy higher the frequency the
higher the energy
and
um here in this picture you can see the
effect of the doppler effect
where when you have a moving source
um the observer sees the waveline
modified
objects which move towards us
are blue shifted
starting from white light or green light
in this example and objects which move
away from us are shifted
the effect can be used for example in
in
speed measurements of cast they can also
use in order to measure speed or
distances of stars moving away from us
and so that defines then the concept of
redshift which is simply the ratio of
the
the difference in wavelengths divided by
the wavelength of as observed by the
observer
so here there's two concept questions
the first one is
is the wave equation which you can see
there as an example invariant on the
lawrence transformation
and the second question is how about the
solutions are the solutions to the
weight equation environment and the
learner's transformation
so have you worked this out again
and the answers are
yes and no
the wave equation is invariant the wave
equation describes the physics it gives
explains how electric magnetic fields
change and
the laws of physics need to be invariant
in the learn's transformation otherwise
they will not be valid we will violate
the poster that we just made that all
reference frame are equal to each other
however the solutions of the wave
equation the light itself is not
invariant under lawrence transformation
we've just discussed redshift and
blueshift which means that the
wavelength and frequency of light
changes with respect to the observer or
for each observer so solutions light are
not environmentally
and then we went a little bit into
particle physics and i have to apologize
for my own preference
but elementary particles as i have been
produced or observed are typically
moving at rather large velocity so
they're very good examples to study
effects of special relativity
we looked at energy the total energy m
naught gamma c square uh which is also
can be expressed as the energy of the
rest the rest energy of the particle m
naught c square plus the kinetic energy
and we looked at the total energy as
being invariant one of those invariants
as equal to the total momenta squared
the total energy squared is equal to the
total momentum square times c squared
plus the mass the rest mass square times
c to the fourth power and then we went
through a larger number of examples
from accelerating electrons to composite
particles we talked about
deuteron photon absorption and admission
the creation of particle the creation of
anti-particles and the scattering of
particles so here yet another example
oops without the solution
in 1995
at fermilab the proton anti-proton
collider the tabertron
top quarks that is covered and we
measured the top cork mass to 175 gb
um the center of mass energy at the
temperature was 1.8 and later almost two
tera electron volt
and clearly sufficient for the
production of top and rd
but what is the minimal energy in order
for this process to occur
and here
we went through a number of examples um
the minimal energy so
if we work this out again the minimal
energy
required
can be
derived or extracted in the center of
mass frame where the top and anti-top
are produced at rest
and if you do this in this example the
proton in this collider experiment
the experiment is already conducted in
the center of mass so the mineral energy
is simply 2 times the top mass times c
square or 2 times gamma times the mass
of the proton times c square which gives
you a gamma factor of 175
but the likelihood to actually observe
anti the top cork and the anti-top cork
and that energy 175 geb
um
proton or anti-potent energy
is uh is rather
zero and the reason for this is has to
do with the structure of the proton the
actual interaction between the proton
and the anti-proton is such that the
quarks inside the quarks and antiquarks
inside the protons and also the gluons
interact and they only carry a fraction
of the momentum and the energy of the
proton and hence this minimal
calculation is insufficient to get a
sufficient cross-section likelihood for
top quarks and anti-blocks to be
produced but that is particle physics
and goes beyond the scope of this
lecture
one last point which leads sometimes to
confusion
is the concept of conserved and
invariant properties
so if you look at the meaning of the
word
invariant means never changing and in
the concept of special relativity
properties are invariant when they do
not change under lawrence transformation
or galilean transformation as we
discussed earlier in the class
you